I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey.
We were on The Office together and we're best friends.
And now we're doing the ultimate Office Lovers podcast just for you.
Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews
behind the scenes details and lots of BFF stories.
We're the Office Lady 6.0.
Hi there, Angela.
Hey, good morning.
I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate Office Lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews behind the scenes details and lots of BFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0. Hi there, Angela. Hey, good morning.|||我是珍娜·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了这款终极的《办公室》爱好者播客。每周我们都会通过独家采访、幕后细节和大量闺蜜故事，带你更深入地了解《办公室》的世界。我们是“办公室女士 6.0”。嗨，安吉拉。嘿，早安。
Good morning.
We have a really fun friendship episode for you today in honor of Best Friends Day coming up.
We teamed up with the folks at the podcast The Moth to help us share some stories about the power of friendship.
You know, last year for Best Friends Day, we shared our own stories of friendship as well as some of yours.
It was such a lovely episode.
So I'm excited to dive into the theme of friendship again this year.
So big thanks to The Moth.
Yeah.
Good morning. We have a really fun friendship episode for you today in honor of Best Friends Day coming up. We teamed up with the folks at the podcast The Moth to help us share some stories about the power of friendship. You know, last year for Best Friends Day, we shared our own stories of friendship as well as some of yours. It was such a lovely episode. So I'm excited to dive into the theme of friendship again this year. So big thanks to The Moth. Yeah.|||早安。为了庆即将到来的挚友日，我们今天为你准备了一期非常有趣的关于友谊的节目。我们与播客节目《故事 Moth》的工作人员合作，共同分享一些关于友谊力量的故事。你知道，去年在挚友日那天，我们分享了我们自己的友谊故事以及你们的一些故事。那一集真是太美好了。所以我很高兴今年能再次探讨友谊这个主题。非常感谢《故事 Moth》。是的。
But first, let's start with our chit-chat suggestion from Sienna in Australia.
Sienna says, hi, Angela and Jenna.
My name is Sienna, and I'm an 18-year-old.
old osteopathie student from Australia. I've had a rough couple of years as I was severely bullied
by my so-called friends, found out my mother has a luckily benign, vasavagal tumor, as well as being
diagnosed with ADHD all within my final year of schooling. I was aiming for a career in medicine
and fell short, which was honestly devastating for me, as it felt like I had failed my one and
only lifelong dream. However, then I found your podcast.
But first, let's start with our chit-chat suggestion from Sienna in Australia. Sienna says, hi, Angela and Jenna. My name is Sienna, and I'm an 18-year-old. old osteopathie student from Australia. I've had a rough couple of years as I was severely bullied by my so-called friends, found out my mother has a luckily benign, vasavagal tumor, as well as being diagnosed with ADHD all within my final year of schooling. I was aiming for a career in medicine and fell short, which was honestly devastating for me, as it felt like I had failed my one and only lifelong dream. However, then I found your podcast.|||但首先，让我们从澳大利亚的西耶娜发来的闲聊建议开始。西耶娜说，嗨，安吉拉和珍娜。我叫西耶娜，是一名来自澳大利亚的18岁整骨疗法专业学生。过去几年我过得很艰难，在学业的最后一年里，我不仅遭到所谓朋友的严重欺凌，发现母亲患有（幸好是良性的）迷走神经性肿瘤，还被诊断出患有注意力缺陷多动障碍（ADHD）。我曾以从医为目标却未能如愿，这对我来说简直是毁灭性的打击，因为这感觉就像我辜负了自己唯一且毕生的梦想。然而，就在那时我发现了你们的播客。
And having struggled with friendships recently, and always being told I was born 40,
it was so comforting to find my two new best friends that I could listen to anywhere.
The show is honestly just so comforting to me and has helped me to feel supported,
less alone, and like I can continue to strive for dreams even after setbacks.
Your friendship has helped me know what I would like in a friendship and has helped me to build
the confidence to make lots of new friends at university with you behind me.
So I just wanted to say thank you for the comfort that this podcast brings me.
It always helps me to calm down and feels like I'm having a chat with old friends.
And having struggled with friendships recently, and always being told I was born 40, it was so comforting to find my two new best friends that I could listen to anywhere. The show is honestly just so comforting to me and has helped me to feel supported, less alone, and like I can continue to strive for dreams even after setbacks. Your friendship has helped me know what I would like in a friendship and has helped me to build the confidence to make lots of new friends at university with you behind me. So I just wanted to say thank you for the comfort that this podcast brings me. It always helps me to calm down and feels like I'm having a chat with old friends.|||由于最近在友谊上饱受挣扎，而且总是被人说我少年老成，能找到我随时随地都能听的两个新好朋友，这太令人感到慰藉了。这个节目对真我而言实在是莫大的抚慰，它让我感受到了支持，不再孤单，并且觉得即使经历挫折，我也能继续为梦想奋斗。你们的友谊让我明白了自己对友谊的期望，并在你们的支持下，帮我树立了在大学里结交许多新朋友的信心。所以我只是想对这个播客带给我的慰藉表达感谢。它总是能帮我平静下来，感觉就像是在和老朋友聊天一样。
Love you guys.
P.S. I've also started a crochet business at at Sienna Rose Crochetes and love to make wacky little decorations that are perfect for a podcasting closet or that's what she shed.
Oh, Sienna, thank you for your really touching and vulnerable letter.
And she included a photo of her with her friends.
that is just amazing.
Just such a lovely group.
You know, Sienna, you are a bright spot in the world.
I loved your letter.
Love you guys. P.S. I've also started a crochet business at at Sienna Rose Crochetes and love to make wacky little decorations that are perfect for a podcasting closet or that's what she shed. Oh, Sienna, thank you for your really touching and vulnerable letter. And she included a photo of her with her friends. that is just amazing. Just such a lovely group. You know, Sienna, you are a bright spot in the world. I loved your letter.|||爱你们。附言：我还创办了一家名为“西耶娜·罗斯钩针”的钩针编织小生意，喜欢制作各种古怪的小装饰品，非常适合放在播客衣橱里，或者这就是所谓的“女性小屋”。哦，西耶娜，谢谢你这封感人肺腑又袒露心声的信。她还附上了一张她和朋友们的照片，真是太棒了。多么可爱的一个群体啊。你知道的，西耶娜，你是世界上的一个小亮点。我很喜欢你的信。
I also went and checked out your crochet business.
You are so talented.
And I just want to thank you for writing in.
I want to thank you for sharing your journey with friendships.
I'm just sending you a big hug.
I also want to say to Sienna and anyone else out there that might be experiencing a rough patch in friendship.
is that I've had ebbs and flows of friendship bonds in my life too.
I had a really tough middle school experience.
I also went and checked out your crochet business. You are so talented. And I just want to thank you for writing in. I want to thank you for sharing your journey with friendships. I'm just sending you a big hug. I also want to say to Sienna and anyone else out there that might be experiencing a rough patch in friendship. is that I've had ebbs and flows of friendship bonds in my life too. I had a really tough middle school experience.|||我还去查看了你的钩针编织生意。你太有才了。我只想感谢你写信来。我想感谢你分享你的友谊历程。我要给你一个大大的拥抱。我还想对西耶娜以及其他任何可能正在经历友谊低谷的人说，我的生活中也有过友谊纽带的起起伏伏。我有一段非常艰难的中学经历。
It was that kind of subtle, mean girl energy, but coming from people who were my friends.
And it was just such a heavy load.
And I actually ended up leaving that school.
And I found a wonderful friend group at my new high school.
But then in college, I had a hard time making really good friends again.
Like I had the theater folks, but I didn't have like that really great bond.
So like middle school was rough, high school was great, college was me.
And I know I've shared this before, but it really wasn't until Angela and I met in my 30s that I experienced that kind of best friendship bond that I had felt with my high school friends.
It was that kind of subtle, mean girl energy, but coming from people who were my friends. And it was just such a heavy load. And I actually ended up leaving that school. And I found a wonderful friend group at my new high school. But then in college, I had a hard time making really good friends again. Like I had the theater folks, but I didn't have like that really great bond. So like middle school was rough, high school was great, college was me. And I know I've shared this before, but it really wasn't until Angela and I met in my 30s that I experienced that kind of best friendship bond that I had felt with my high school friends.|||那种感觉就像是微妙的“刻薄女孩”气场，但却来自那些自称是我朋友的人。这真的是一个沉重的负担。我甚至最后不得不离开了那所学校。我在新的高中找到了一群很棒的朋友。但到了大学，我又很难交到真正的好朋友了。比如我有戏剧社的朋友，但我没有那种特别深厚的羁绊。所以就好像中学很难熬，高中很棒，大学很一般。我知道我以前分享过，但直到我和安吉拉在我30多岁时相遇，我才真正体验到了那种曾与高中朋友感受过的最好朋友之间的纽带。
So I had droughts too.
I related to that.
There's definitely hills and valleys in the course of your life when it comes to friendship.
You know, my mom gave me advice years ago. I was in my late 20s and struggling with some friendships.
You know, it's hard when you move away or if your life takes you in new directions. I was feeling a little lost.
And my mom said, and you have so many amazing people in your life. I encourage you to invest in those that invest in you.
That has stuck with me. I remember it like the day she said it and something just clicked for me.
and I looked around at the people in my life, at my friends at that time, and there were always
So I had droughts too. I related to that. There's definitely hills and valleys in the course of your life when it comes to friendship. You know, my mom gave me advice years ago. I was in my late 20s and struggling with some friendships. You know, it's hard when you move away or if your life takes you in new directions. I was feeling a little lost. And my mom said, and you have so many amazing people in your life. I encourage you to invest in those that invest in you. That has stuck with me. I remember it like the day she said it and something just clicked for me. and I looked around at the people in my life, at my friends at that time, and there were always|||所以我也有过缺乏友谊的“干旱期”。我对此很有共鸣。在人的一生中，说到友谊，肯定会有高潮和低谷。你知道的，我妈妈多年前曾给我过一个建议。那时我快三十岁了，正在为一些友谊苦恼。你知道的，当你搬到外地或者生活把你带向新的方向时，这很难。我当时感觉有点迷茫。我妈妈说，你的生活中其实有那么多优秀的人。我鼓励你去投资那些也对你付出投资的人。这句话一直铭刻在我心中。我记得就像她说的当天一样清晰，有些东西突然让我开窍了。我环顾了我生活中的人，环顾了我当时的朋友，发现总有那么些人……
people that I was chasing after to be my friend. And then there were these core people who were
there for me no matter what. And they offered me this unconditional love and friendship and support. And so
I made the decision right then and there, I'm going to choose to invest in this group of people
who builds me right back up. And that really was a turning point.
for me and how I look at friendships. That's great advice. Yeah. Well, this is a little bit of a tangent,
but I just read the book, The Correspondent. Oh, you said you loved it. I loved it. It lived up to all
the hype. People have been talking about this book. This is like a late to the party moment.
Like in the book world, everyone's like, yeah, we read the correspondent already. Yeah.
people that I was chasing after to be my friend. And then there were these core people who were there for me no matter what. And they offered me this unconditional love and friendship and support. And so I made the decision right then and there, I'm going to choose to invest in this group of people who builds me right back up. And that really was a turning point. for me and how I look at friendships. That's great advice. Yeah. Well, this is a little bit of a tangent, but I just read the book, The Correspondent. Oh, you said you loved it. I loved it. It lived up to all the hype. People have been talking about this book. This is like a late to the party moment. Like in the book world, everyone's like, yeah, we read the correspondent already. Yeah.|||我一直在追逐着他们，想让他们成为我的朋友。然后还有这样一群核心的人，无论发生什么，他们都在我身边。他们给予我无条件的爱、友谊和支持。所以就在那一分那一秒，我做出了决定，我要选择把精力投入到这群能重新支撑起我的人身上。这对我看待友谊的方式来说确实是一个转折点。真是个绝佳的建议。是的。嗯，这有点扯远了，但我刚读了一本书叫《通信者》（The Correspondent）。哦，你说你很喜欢它。我很喜欢。它名副其实。大家都在谈论这本书。这就像是一个“后知后觉”的时刻。就像在书的世界里，每个人都觉得，“对啊，我们早就读过《通信者》了。”是的。
But I just read it. It's great. It's told all through letters. So it's just a series of letters.
and the main protagonist is this woman.
She's in her 70s, and you're seeing her right to all kinds of people, and then you see their
responses.
But I was particularly taken with the letters between her and her best friend.
It was such a wonderful friendship.
Angela, it reminded me of our friendship because there was just this unconditional love between
these two women who had known each other for a very, very long time.
But I just read it. It's great. It's told all through letters. So it's just a series of letters. and the main protagonist is this woman. She's in her 70s, and you're seeing her right to all kinds of people, and then you see their responses. But I was particularly taken with the letters between her and her best friend. It was such a wonderful friendship. Angela, it reminded me of our friendship because there was just this unconditional love between these two women who had known each other for a very, very long time.|||但我刚刚才读。它太棒了。整个故事完全通过信件来讲述。所以它只是一系列的信件。主角是一位女性。她已经70多岁了，你会看到她给各种各样的人写信，然后看到他们的回信。但我尤其被她和她最好朋友之间的信件所吸引。那是一段多么美妙的友谊啊。安吉拉，这让我想起了我们的友谊，因为这两个认识了非常非常长时间的女性之间，存在着那种无条件的爱。
and I just loved it.
And I think if anyone out there is looking for like a really good example of a great female
friendship, you can find it in this book.
Well, I've got to read it.
It's so good.
So good.
Well, listen, why don't we take a break?
And when we come back, we will hear three wonderful stories from the folks at the moth.
and I just loved it. And I think if anyone out there is looking for like a really good example of a great female friendship, you can find it in this book. Well, I've got to read it. It's so good. So good. Well, listen, why don't we take a break? And when we come back, we will hear three wonderful stories from the folks at the moth.|||我简直太喜欢了。我想如果外面的任何人正在寻找伟大女性友谊的一个绝佳范例，你可以在这本书里找到它。好吧，我一定要读读看。它太棒了。太棒了。好了，听着，我们为什么不休息一下呢？等我们回来时，我们将听到来自《故事 Moth》朋友们的三个精彩故事。
Yeah, the moth is hosted by Chloe Salmon.
And it features true stories told live.
It's real people.
anyone from like an astronaut to an actor, a teacher, a truck driver, scientists, singers,
people who are getting up on stage and then they tell a story about their own lives in their
own words.
I love nights like this.
I did some of this back in my theater improv days.
Yeah, the moth is hosted by Chloe Salmon. And it features true stories told live. It's real people. anyone from like an astronaut to an actor, a teacher, a truck driver, scientists, singers, people who are getting up on stage and then they tell a story about their own lives in their own words. I love nights like this. I did some of this back in my theater improv days.|||是的，《故事 Moth》由克洛伊·萨尔蒙（Chloe Salmon）主持。它以现场讲述的真实故事为特色。讲故事的都是真人，任何人——从宇航员到演员、老师、卡车司机、科学家、歌手，这些走上舞台，用他们自己的话讲述自己生活故事的人。我爱这样的夜晚。我当年在戏剧即兴表演的日子里也做过类似的事情。
I did it too.
Open mic nights where they'd have a monologist.
Yes.
They're so great.
Well, the stories featured on The Moth are really funny, sometimes enlightening, heartbreaking,
sometimes all three at the same time.
And we think that if you like the sense of connection and fun that is office ladies
or that feeling where you're getting a new perspective on someone's life,
I did it too. Open mic nights where they'd have a monologist. Yes. They're so great. Well, the stories featured on The Moth are really funny, sometimes enlightening, heartbreaking, sometimes all three at the same time. And we think that if you like the sense of connection and fun that is office ladies or that feeling where you're getting a new perspective on someone's life,|||我也做过。有独白演员的开放麦之夜。是的。它们太棒了。嗯，《故事 Moth》上的故事真的非常有趣，有时充满启发，有时又令人心碎，有时这三者同时具备。我们认为，如果你喜欢《办公室女士》所带来的那种连接感和乐趣，或者那种让你对某人的人生获得新视角的感受……
that the moth has a lot of those same vibes.
Absolutely.
And the episode we're sharing today, BFFs, is about something we explore quite a bit on
office ladies and that is friendship.
And then later, we will be back with some final thoughts on friendship.
Welcome to the moth.
I'm Chloe Salmon.
There are so many stories about romantic love, which is fair, I guess.
that the moth has a lot of those same vibes. Absolutely. And the episode we're sharing today, BFFs, is about something we explore quite a bit on office ladies and that is friendship. And then later, we will be back with some final thoughts on friendship. Welcome to the moth. I'm Chloe Salmon. There are so many stories about romantic love, which is fair, I guess.|||……那么《故事 Moth》也有很多这种相同的氛围。绝对是的。我们今天分享的这一集《闺蜜（BFFs）》，探讨的正是我们在《办公室女士》中经常探讨的话题——友谊。稍后，我们将带着对友谊的一些最后感悟回到节目中。欢迎来到《故事 Moth》。我是克洛伊·萨尔蒙。有那么多关于浪漫爱情的故事，我想这也无可厚非。
But I take your romantic love and raise you a different relationship,
one that can be just as fulfilling and, honestly, sometimes even more so.
Friendship.
I'm grateful for my friends every day,
because each and every one of them is a perfect, beautiful angel who supports me fiercely,
but is also willing to give me an honest opinion about the new haircut I want to try out.
Without them, I would be a lonely girl with a girl.
the bowl cut I thought would look French, probably.
But I take your romantic love and raise you a different relationship, one that can be just as fulfilling and, honestly, sometimes even more so. Friendship. I'm grateful for my friends every day, because each and every one of them is a perfect, beautiful angel who supports me fiercely, but is also willing to give me an honest opinion about the new haircut I want to try out. Without them, I would be a lonely girl with a girl. the bowl cut I thought would look French, probably.|||但我收起你的浪漫爱情，并向你抛出一种不同的关系——一种同样能让人感到充实，而且说实话，有时甚至有过之而无不及的关系。友谊。我每天都对我的朋友们心怀感激，因为他们每一个人都是完美、美丽的可爱天使，他们坚定地支持我，但也愿意就我想尝试的新发型给我诚实的意见。如果没有他们，我就会是一个孤独的女孩，顶着一个我以为会很有法式风情的蘑菇头，大概吧。
In this episode, three stories all about friendship,
from how they can be there for you during challenging times,
to a friend's unconditional love to the gummy bears.
Don't worry, we'll get there.
First up is Lauren Karch,
who told this story at a main stage in Dayton, Ohio,
where the theme was more than meets the eye.
Here's Lauren. Light at the Mock.
In this episode, three stories all about friendship, from how they can be there for you during challenging times, to a friend's unconditional love to the gummy bears. Don't worry, we'll get there. First up is Lauren Karch, who told this story at a main stage in Dayton, Ohio, where the theme was more than meets the eye. Here's Lauren. Light at the Mock.|||在本期节目中，有三个完全关于友谊的故事：从他们如何在充满挑战的时期陪伴在你身边，到朋友无条件的爱，再到小熊软糖。别担心，我们等会儿就会讲到。首先登场的是劳伦·卡奇（Lauren Karch），她在俄亥俄州代顿市的主舞台上讲述了这个故事，当时的主题是“表象之下”。有请劳伦。《故事 Moth》现场。
So a couple years ago,
I started to notice that people were sounding quieter to me,
which did not track with world events,
but only when I was on the phone
and only when I had the phone to the right side of my head.
And it wasn't like just that.
I also noticed like I would get dizzy sometimes
and sometimes I kind of felt like my head was underwater.
So a couple years ago, I started to notice that people were sounding quieter to me, which did not track with world events, but only when I was on the phone and only when I had the phone to the right side of my head. And it wasn't like just that. I also noticed like I would get dizzy sometimes and sometimes I kind of felt like my head was underwater.|||所以几年前，我开始注意到人们说话的声音在我听来变小了，这与世界大势完全无关，但这种情况只在我打电话时出现，而且只有当我把电话贴在右耳旁时才会这样。不仅如此。我还注意到我有时会头晕，有时甚至感觉自己的脑袋好像浸在水里一样。
So I held off, but eventually I made an appointment
with like an ear, nose and throat specialist
and got my hearing tested.
And I found out exactly what I did not want to know,
which was that at like 32, I was losing my hearing.
But only on one side.
And my doctor started going through a list of other tests I could try and possible diagnoses.
And I interrupted him and said, did I tell you my dad has Meneers disease?
So I held off, but eventually I made an appointment with like an ear, nose and throat specialist and got my hearing tested. And I found out exactly what I did not want to know, which was that at like 32, I was losing my hearing. But only on one side. And my doctor started going through a list of other tests I could try and possible diagnoses. And I interrupted him and said, did I tell you my dad has Meneers disease?|||所以我一直拖着没去，但最终我还是预约了一位耳鼻喉科专家并做了听力测试。结果发现了我最不想知道的事情——大约在32岁时，我正在失去听力。而且只有单侧。我的医生开始罗列我可以尝试的其他检查以及可能的诊断结果。我打断了他，说道：“我跟你说过我爸爸患有梅尼埃病吗？”
And he looked at me, you know, like how you do when you're looking at the answer to a trivia question.
My dad lost his hearing completely within like 10 years of being diagnosed.
So I knew that if I had the same deal, like the same thing could happen to me.
You know, I'd probably lose the rest of my hearing on my right side and maybe both ears.
like within a few years or sooner or later or not at all.
And usually I'm not like the kind of person who's like,
oh, I got to know what's going to happen.
Because I'm not picking the restaurant, okay?
And he looked at me, you know, like how you do when you're looking at the answer to a trivia question. My dad lost his hearing completely within like 10 years of being diagnosed. So I knew that if I had the same deal, like the same thing could happen to me. You know, d probably lose the rest of my hearing on my right side and maybe both ears. like within a few years or sooner or later or not at all. And usually I'm not like the kind of person who's like, oh, I got to know what's going to happen. Because I'm not picking the restaurant, okay?|||他看着我，你知道的，就像你看益智问答题答案时的那种眼神。我爸爸在确诊大约10年内就完全失聪了。所以我知道，如果我的情况一样，同样的事情也可能会发生在我身上。你知道的，我右耳剩余的听力可能会丧失，甚至可能两只耳朵都失聪，可能在几年内，或早或晚，或者根本不会。通常我不是那种会说“哦，我必须知道接下来会发生什么”的人。因为连餐厅都不是我挑的，好吗？
I'm not like a type A person.
I do not have what the teens call main character energy.
But in this moment, like I wish that I did
because there's not really a treatment for Mnirre's.
So like you can take symptom stuff so I could do like short-term steroids
to word off the vertigo.
And my doctor told me to avoid caffeine and salt, which are like my two favorite food groups.
So that weekend I visited my parents.
I'm not like a type A person. I do not have what the teens call main character energy. But in this moment, like I wish that I did because there's not really a treatment for Mnirre's. So like you can take symptom stuff so I could do like short-term steroids to word off the vertigo. And my doctor told me to avoid caffeine and salt, which are like my two favorite food groups. So that weekend I visited my parents.|||我不是那种A型人格的人。我没有青少年们所说的“主角光环”。但在那一刻，我真希望我有，因为梅尼埃病并没有什么真正的治疗方法。所以你只能服用一些针对症状的药物，比如我可以短期使用类固醇来预防眩晕。我的医生还告诉我避免摄入咖啡因和盐，这恰好是我最喜欢的两类“食物”。所以那个周末我去看望了我的父母。
And it's never like nice to start a conversation with,
what if I end up like you? But that's basically what I did to my dad.
And you told me, you know, a few things. He was like, there's all this assistive technology
and like supportive community for people with hearing loss.
And frankly, it's not a huge tragedy, not hear everybody all the time in this economy.
My dad's a very, like, Zen, very, like, believes in a higher path kind of person.
So that kind of brought me out of my, like, basement of depression.
But a few months later, I was back at the same doctor's office
And it's never like nice to start a conversation with, what if I end up like you? But that's basically what I did to my dad. And you told me, you know, a few things. He was like, there's all this assistive technology and like supportive community for people with hearing loss. And frankly, it's not a huge tragedy, not hear everybody all the time in this economy. My dad's a very, like, Zen, very, like, believes in a higher path kind of person. So that kind of brought me out of my, like, basement of depression. But a few months later, I was back at the same doctor's office|||用“如果我最后变得跟你一样怎么办？”来开启一段对话，从来都不是一件美妙的事。但这基本上就是我对爸爸说的话。他告诉我了一些事情。他说，现在有很多针对听力损失人群的辅助技术和支持社区。坦白说，在这个经济环境下，并不是时时刻刻都能听到每个人的声音也不是什么大悲剧。我爸爸是一个非常禅意、非常相信更高指引的人。所以这在某种程度上把我从抑郁的谷底中拉了出来了。但几个月后，我又回到了同一家诊所……
because I kept getting these episodes of, like, room spinning vertigo,
and my hearing was worse.
So they retested me, and I was up to 80 decibels of loss in my right ear,
which they have the little, like, dumb layman's term chart in the soundproof booth.
So that means that on my right side, I can hear things that are louder than, quote,
a lawnmower at close range, which is awesome.
And so I went home, and I got on Reddit like you do
when you're looking up rare diseases.
because I kept getting these episodes of, like, room spinning vertigo, and my hearing was worse. So they retested me, and I was up to 80 decibels of loss in my right ear, which they have the little, like, dumb layman's term chart in the soundproof booth. So that means that on my right side, I can hear things that are louder than, quote, a lawnmower at close range, which is awesome. And so I went home, and I got on Reddit like you do when you're looking up rare diseases.|||因为我不断经历那种天旋地转的眩晕发作，而且我的听力更差了。所以他们重新给我做了测试，我的右耳听力损失已经达到了80分贝，隔音室内有一张那种简单易懂的通俗术语图表。这意味着在我的右侧，我只能听到比“近距离割草机”声音更大的声音，这真是太棒了。于是我回到家，上了红迪网（Reddit），就像你在查询罕见病时会做的那样。
And I found this interview with an artist
who also had Maneer's disease,
and the interviewer had asked him,
I thought it was such a good question.
What sound do you miss the most?
And he was like a poet or something.
So he said, I most miss the soft sound of a cat laughing water
because it sounds so satisfying for the cat.
And I found this interview with an artist who also had Maneer's disease, and the interviewer had asked him, I thought it was such a good question. What sound do you miss the most? And he was like a poet or something. So he said, I most miss the soft sound of a cat laughing water because it sounds so satisfying for the cat.|||我找到了对一位同样患有梅尼埃病的艺术家的采访，采访者问了他一个问题，我觉得这个问题太棒了：“你最怀念什么声音？”他好像是个诗人什么的。所以他说：“我最怀念猫咪喝水时发出的柔和声音，因为听起来对猫来说是那么的满足。”
So I found myself then sitting on my living room floor,
sort of like sloshing a water bowl towards my increasingly disgruntled cat.
And Teradactyl, that's my cat's name.
She was not satisfied.
She just looked at me like, I don't get paid enough for this.
But the question had given me kind of an idea of something I could do
to feel a little bit more in control.
I thought, I should make a list of everything I want to hear
So I found myself then sitting on my living room floor, sort of like sloshing a water bowl towards my increasingly disgruntled cat. And Teradactyl, that's my cat's name. She was not satisfied. She just looked at me like, I don't get paid enough for this. But the question had given me kind of an idea of something I could do to feel a little bit more in control. I thought, I should make a list of everything I want to hear|||于是我发现自己当时正坐在客厅的地板上，拿着一个水碗，朝着我那越来越不满的猫晃荡着水。特拉代克蒂尔（Teradactyl），那是我的猫的名字。她一点也不满意。她只是看着我，眼神仿佛在说：“我的工资可不包含干这个。”但这个问题给了我一个灵感，让我觉得可以做点什么来找回一点掌控感。我想，我应该列一个清单，记下所有我想听到的声音……
before I go deaf, in case I go deaf, like,
a playlist bucket list, right?
Like, yeah, I probably can't afford to go to the Amazon rainforest
right now, but I could leave the window open when it rains.
And like, I didn't want the last thing I heard
to be like a spam call or like myself repeating gossip, you know?
And so when I saw a few days later that my favorite band
was going to be in Cincinnati, I bought tickets right away.
before I go deaf, in case I go deaf, like, a playlist bucket list, right? Like, yeah, I probably can't afford to go to the Amazon rainforest right now, but I could leave the window open when it rains. And like, I didn't want the last thing I heard to be like a spam call or like myself repeating gossip, you know? And so when I saw a few days later that my favorite band was going to be in Cincinnati, I bought tickets right away.|||在我失聪之前——万一我真的失聪了的话——比如一个播放列表愿望清单，对吧？比如，是的，我现在可能去不起亚马逊雨林，但下雨时我可以把窗户打开。而且，我可不想我听到的最后一句话是垃圾诈骗电话，或者是我自己在那儿重复八卦，你知道吗？所以几天后，当我看到我最喜欢的乐队要在辛辛那提演出时，我立刻买了票。
I did not think about who I was going to take with me.
But then I happened to go to Warehouse 4,
my favorite coffee shop later.
And yeah.
And my friend Stacy was working.
And Stacy is like the kind of person who was up for anything.
Plus it was really swamped in there.
So it was the perfect time to entrap her with an invitation.
I did not think about who I was going to take with me. But then I happened to go to Warehouse 4, my favorite coffee shop later. And yeah. And my friend Stacy was working. And Stacy is like the kind of person who was up for anything. Plus it was really swamped in there. So it was the perfect time to entrap her with an invitation.|||我当时根本没想过要带谁一起去。但后来我碰巧去了我最喜欢的咖啡店“4号仓库”（Warehouse 4）。然后呢，我的朋友斯黛西（Stacy）正在上班。斯黛西就是那种对什么都跃跃欲试的人。再加上当时店里非常忙碌。所以这正是用邀请“套路”她的绝佳时机。
And she agreed to go.
And like, yeah, were we a little old to be at Bogarts
under like the no-moshing sign?
Yeah.
So were the mountain goats, my favorite band from 2005.
And Stacy used to be a youth choir director.
So in exchange for me taking her to see a sad dad band,
And she agreed to go. And like, yeah, were we a little old to be at Bogarts under like the no-moshing sign? Yeah. So were the mountain goats, my favorite band from 2005. Yeah. And Stacy used to be a youth choir director. So in exchange for me taking her to see a sad dad band,|||她同意一起去了。而且，好吧，我们在写着“禁止冲撞（no-moshing）”标语的博加特（Bogarts）酒吧是不是有点太老了？是的。我2005年最喜欢的乐队“山羊乐队”（Mountain Goats）也是。是的。斯黛西曾经是一名青年合唱团指挥。所以作为我带她去看一支“悲伤老爸乐队”的回报……
she asked me if I would want to go with her to see a children's production of cats,
which, yeah, like, I don't have time to wait for professionals to put on cats for me.
And I realized, like, I could knock off a ton of kinds of music
if I started going to, like, the free concerts put on by, like, the library and YSO.
So, like, jazz in the park.
jazz at the Culture Center. Jazz at the library. There's a lot of jazz. I got really into it.
I accompanied my boyfriend, who was on his own journey, of trying to see every Boston sports team
play in the Midwest. And I don't really like sports, but I did want to hear his accent being
she asked me if I would want to go with her to see a children's production of cats, which, yeah, like, I don't have time to wait for professionals to put on cats for me. And I realized, like, I could knock off a ton of kinds of music if I started going to, like, the free concerts put on by, like, the library and YSO. So, like, jazz in the park. jazz at the Culture Center. Jazz at the library. There's a lot of jazz. I got really into it. I accompanied my boyfriend, who was on his own journey, of trying to see every Boston sports team play in the Midwest. And I don't really like sports, but I did want to hear his accent being|||她问我想不想和她一起去看儿童版的音乐剧《猫》。这嘛，就像是，我可没时间等专业人士来为我表演《猫》了。我意识到，如果我开始去参加诸如图书馆和青年交响乐团（YSO）举办的免费音乐会，我可以一下子打卡好多种类的音乐。比如，公园里的爵士乐。文化中心的爵士乐。图书馆里的爵士乐。有好多爵士乐。我真的迷上了它。我陪着男友，踏上了他自己的旅程——试图在中西部看遍每一支波士顿运动队的比赛。我其实并不喜欢体育运动，但我确实想听听他的口音……
used for its intended purpose, which is cursing the Red Sox.
And I started listening to my mom's favorite true crime podcast because I wanted to see if I, like
her, could learn to discern who was guilty based on the guilt in the murderer's voice.
And kind of, yeah.
But the biggest victim in all this was my best friend, Katie.
I had told her about my hearing problems,
but I didn't tell her about the playlist,
because it's insane.
used for its intended purpose, which is cursing the Red Sox. And I started listening to my mom's favorite true crime podcast because I wanted to see if I, like her, could learn to discern who was guilty based on the guilt in the murderer's voice. And kind of, yeah. But the biggest victim in all this was my best friend, Katie. I had told her about my hearing problems, but I didn't tell her about the playlist, because it's insane.|||……用在它原本的目的上，那就是用来痛骂红织袜队（Red Sox）。我还开始听我妈妈最喜欢的真实犯罪播客，因为我想看看自己是否能像她一样，通过凶手声音中的罪恶感来辨别谁是有罪的。差不多能吧。但这一切中最大的“受害者”是我最好的朋友凯蒂（Katie）。我告诉过她我的听力问题，但我没有告诉她那个播放列表的事，因为这太疯狂了。
But the problem is she's like the perfect person,
perfect man for the job, because she is a theater person.
We actually know each other from the theater
because we came close, like, we became close
in our rural high schools production
of the soul musical The Whiz.
And which is, because it was from the before times.
And so we'd always kind of dreamed of like aging into being those like costume jewelry ladies who like have season tickets to the ballet.
But the problem is she's like the the perfect person, perfect man for the job, because she is a theater person. We actually know each other from the theater because we came close, like, we became close in our rural high schools production of the soul musical The Whiz. And which is, because it was from the before times. And so we'd always kind of dreamed of like aging into being those like costume jewelry ladies who like have season tickets to the ballet.|||但问题是，她简直是这份工作的完美人选，因为她是个戏剧迷。我们其实因戏剧而相识，因为我们在乡村高中的灵魂音乐剧《新绿野仙踪》（The Whiz）的排练中变得亲密起来。那是很久以前的事了。所以我们一直梦想着慢慢变老，成为那种佩戴夸张人造珠宝、拥有芭蕾舞剧季票的优雅老太太。
So I texted her and I said, remember how we were going to become theater ladies?
Like, what if we just do that now?
And she just said, I thought you'd never ask.
So we went, we went to the opera.
We went to all the Dayton Playhouse shows.
And like the Broadway series when it came to town, the poetry slam.
We went and saw that band that dresses like vampires.
You guys, they just got a hearse.
So I texted her and I said, remember how we were going to become theater ladies? Like, what if we just do that now? And she just said, I thought you'd never ask. So we went, we went to the opera. We went to all the Dayton Playhouse shows. And like the Broadway series when it came to town, the poetry slam. We went and saw that band that dresses like vampires. You guys, they just got a hearse.|||于是我发短信给她，说道：“还记得我们说过要成为戏剧名媛吗？如果我们现在就这么做呢？”她只回了一句：“我还以为你永远不会问呢。”于是我们去了，我们去了歌剧院。我们看了代顿剧场的每一场演出。还有百老汇系列巡演来到镇上时，我们去看了诗歌朗诵会。我们还去看那支打扮得像吸血鬼一样的乐队。天哪，他们刚刚买了一辆灵车。
And it was great.
Her younger co-workers wanted to go see Post Malone,
and I was so into it that I not only got a ticket to Post Malone,
I bought us like wide-leg jeans so we wouldn't stand out among like the youths.
And it was a great time.
But I wanted to see this one really artsy play that was out of town.
So we decided to go to that.
And what I learned is there's a level of artsiness that I do not get.
And it was great. Her younger co-workers wanted to go see Post Malone, and I was so into it that I not only got a ticket to Post Malone, I bought us like wide-leg jeans so we wouldn't stand out among like the youths. And it was a great time. But I wanted to see this one really artsy play that was out of town. So we decided to go to that. And what I learned is there's a level of artsiness that I do not get.|||这太棒了。她的年轻同事们想去看波斯特·马龙（Post Malone）的演出，我对此非常感兴趣，以至于我不仅买了一张波斯特·马龙的门票，还给我们买了两条阔腿牛仔裤，这样我们在年轻人当中就不会显得那么突兀了。那是一段美好的时光。但我很想看一部外地的、真正充满艺术气息的话剧。所以我们决定去看那个。而我学到的是，有些艺术高度是我实在无法理解的。
But that's okay. Like, I still heard it.
And we had a great hotel that I'd booked for a great price
because I did not notice that it was a micro-tel with bunk beds.
So I'm laying in the top bunk.
And I've realized, like, I've brought Katie on so many goofy situations now.
I have to tell her what I'm thinking.
So I, like, leaned over, like, I'm at camp.
And I said, you're being a really good friend.
But that's okay. Like, I still heard it. And we had a great hotel that I'd booked for a great price because I did not notice that it was a micro-tel with bunk beds. So I'm laying in the top bunk. And I've realized, like, I've brought Katie on so many goofy situations now. I have to tell her what I'm thinking. So I, like, leaned over, like, I'm at camp. And I said, you're being a really good friend.|||但这没关系。至少，我还是听到了。我们住了一家我以超划算价格预订的绝佳酒店，因为我当时根本没注意到那是一家带有双层床的微型汽车旅馆。所以我躺在上铺。我突然意识到，我把凯蒂带入了这么多荒唐的处境中。我必须把我的想法告诉她。于是我探过身去，就像在夏令营里一样，说道：“你一直是个超级好的朋友。”
And I spilled, like, everything.
I told her about how I was worried that I would go deaf
and maybe I wouldn't be able to communicate with people that I care about,
and what about my job?
And, you know, would I still be able to enjoy the things I enjoy now?
And at that time, Taylor Swift had only put out the first Taylor's version album,
and do I look like I want to miss that?
And she said, okay, okay, I think you're a lot more resilient than you're giving yourself credit for.
And I spilled, like, everything. I told her about how I was worried that I would go deaf and maybe I wouldn't be able to communicate with people that I care about, and what about my job? And, you know, would I still be able to enjoy the things I enjoy now? And at that time, Taylor Swift had only put out the first Taylor's version album, and do I look like I want to miss that? And she said, okay, okay, I think you're a lot more resilient than you're giving yourself credit for.|||然后我把一切都倾吐了出来。我告诉她我多么担心自己会失聪，也许以后无法与我关心的人交流了，我的工作怎么办？还有，你知道的，我还能不能享受我现在喜欢的东西？当时，泰勒·斯威夫特（Taylor Swift）才刚发行了第一张重录版专辑（Taylor's Version），我看起来像是想错过那个的人吗？她说：“好吧，好吧，我觉得你比你自己想象的要坚强得多。”
Also, I'd like to see you try to get rid of me, or any of your friends.
And then she got, like, deadly serious and said,
Should we try to learn ASL?
Because then we could talk about people in the same room.
And I am trying to learn ASL.
I have made it through Soto Pop.
So, but a couple weeks later, Katie texted me
because her mom had tickets to the Dayton Philharmonic.
Also, I'd like to see you try to get rid of me, or any of your friends. And then she got, like, deadly serious and said, Should we try to learn ASL? Because then we could talk about people in the same room. And I am trying to learn ASL. I have made it through Soto Pop. So, but a couple weeks later, Katie texted me because her mom had tickets to the Dayton Philharmonic.|||“而且，我倒想看看你怎么能甩掉我，或者甩掉你的任何朋友。”然后她变得极其严肃，说道：“我们要不要尝试学一下美国手语（ASL）？因为那样我们就可以在同一个房间里用手语八卦别人了。”我确实在尝试学习美国手语。我已经学到“苏打水（Soto Pop）”这一课了。不过几周后，凯蒂发短信给我，因为她妈妈有代顿爱乐乐团的门票。
And like, would I want to go with them?
Of course, because the orchestra is classic theater lady,
because it's fancy.
So we got dressed up.
You guys, we went to the Spaghetti Warehouse.
And yeah.
And we came down, and it was a, and it was
at the Schuster's a beautiful theater, like the whole orchestra. It was so great. But there
And like, would I want to go with them? Of course, because the orchestra is classic theater lady, because it's fancy. So we got dressed up. You guys, we went to the Spaghetti Warehouse. And yeah. And we came down, and it was a, and it was at the Schuster's a beautiful theater, like the whole orchestra. It was so great. But there|||问我想不想和他们一起去？当然想，因为管弦乐队是典型的戏剧名媛风格，因为这很高级。于是我们精心打扮了一番。各位，我们去了“意大利面仓库”（Spaghetti Warehouse）餐厅。然后呢，我们来到舒斯特艺术中心（Schuster's），那是一个美丽的剧院，整个管弦乐队都在那儿。真是太棒了。但在那里……
was this one player in the orchestra, that's a cello player, that I noticed. Because, like,
if I had to describe him, unfortunately, hunky, like, just very tall, very good looking. And he was,
he had those protagonist vibes that I've always wanted. Like, he wasn't just playing, he was
performing. And I pointed him out to Katie, and she said, oh, he's on the cover of the program,
and he was. It wasn't the whole orchestra. It was just like him and his cello and a fog
Like he's the front man for the Dayton Phil Harmonic.
So we're like kind of laughing about this.
And, you know, but the music's like really enthralling.
was this one player in the orchestra, that's a cello player, that I noticed. Because, like, if I had to describe him, unfortunately, hunky, like, just very tall, very good looking. And he was, he had those protagonist vibes that I've always wanted. Like, he wasn't just playing, he was performing. And I pointed him out to Katie, and she said, oh, he's on the cover of the program, and he was. It wasn't the whole orchestra. It was just like him and his cello and a fog Like he's the front man for the Dayton Phil Harmonic. So we're like kind of laughing about this. And, you know, but the music's like really enthralling.|||乐队里有一位演奏员，是个大提琴手，引起了我的注意。因为，如果我必须形容他的话，不幸的是，他很健硕，个子非常高，长相非常帅气。而且他身上有一种我一直渴望的主角气场。就好像他不仅是在演奏，而是在进行一场表演。我指给凯蒂看，她说：“哦，他在节目单封面上呢。”果不其然。那可不是整个管弦乐队的封面。封面上只有他、他的大提琴和一团烟雾，就像他是代顿爱乐乐团的主唱一样。所以我们对此笑了好一阵子。而且，你知道的，音乐真的非常迷人。
It's really cool.
It's a nice experience and I'm having fun with my two friends.
And then it's over.
We walk back to the arts garage where we were all parked
and get in our car.
Katie's driving.
We like get to the garage exit and we're just hooting and hollering
about how funny we are and should we wait by the stage door
It's really cool. It's a nice experience and I'm having fun with my two friends. And then it's over. We walk back to the arts garage where we were all parked and get in our car. Katie's driving. We like get to the garage exit and we're just hooting and hollering about how funny we are and should we wait by the stage door|||真的很酷。这是一次美好的体验，我和我的两个朋友玩得很开心。然后演出结束了。我们走回我们停车的艺术中心车库，上了车。凯蒂开车。我们开到车库出口，还在大声尖叫欢呼，谈论着我们有多搞笑，要不要去后台门口等他……
and all this.
And like the garage,
the garage, like the arm thing lifts, and she kind of guns it to pull out of the parking garage
and then slams on her brakes. Because there, in the middle of North Ludlow, and we're barreling
right at him. It's the hot cellist, and he's got his cello on his back, he's got his headphones
in his ears. He's on his own audio journey, clearly. And Katie's mom points straight through
the windshield and screams, don't hit him. And at that moment, I realized, like, this is something
of a universal experience, really. Whether I go deaf or not, everyone's going to be.
and all this. And like the garage, the garage, like the arm thing lifts, and she kind of guns it to pull out of the parking garage and then slams on her brakes. Because there, in the middle of North Ludlow, and we're barreling right at him. It's the hot cellist, and he's got his cello on his back, he's got his headphones in his ears. He's on his own audio journey, clearly. And Katie's mom points straight through the windshield and screams, don't hit him. And at that moment, I realized, like, this is something of a universal experience, really. Whether I go deaf or not, everyone's going to be.|||……诸如此类的话。然后车库的栏杆升起来了，她一踩油门准备驶出停车场，接着猛地踩下了刹车。因为就在那儿，在北勒德洛街（North Ludlow）的正中间，我们正朝他猛冲过去。那是那个性感的大提琴手，他背着大提琴，耳朵里塞着耳机。很明显，他正沉浸在自己的音乐世界里。凯蒂的妈妈隔着挡风玻璃往前一指，尖叫道：“别撞到他！”那一刻我突然意识到，这其实是一种普遍的人生体验。无论我最终会不会失聪，每个人都将……
hear their last thing. And so now I get my hearing tested annually. And the last few times,
like yeah, I am pretty deaf in my right ear. But I always ask the tech, like, oh, is there
any change? And she usually tells me no before the doctor, like, even comes in, at least the last
two times, which is such a relief. So I might still get to hear reputation Taylor's version
with my own natural ears. But I learned about, like, a new way to connect.
with people, and I supported the shit out of the arts.
And I learned that Dayton is like full of these big, bold main characters, and there's still
time to be one.
hear their last thing. And so now I get my hearing tested annually. And the last few times, like yeah, I am pretty deaf in my right ear. But I always ask the tech, like, oh, is there any change? And she usually tells me no before the doctor, like, even comes in, at least the last two times, which is such a relief. So I might still get to hear reputation Taylor's version with my own natural ears. But I learned about, like, a new way to connect. with people, and I supported the shit out of the arts. And I learned that Dayton is like full of these big, bold main characters, and there's still time to be one.|||……听到他们人生的最后的声音。所以现在我每年都会去做一次听力测试。过去几次测试结果显示，是的，我的右耳确实已经快失聪了。但我总是问技术员：“哦，有什么变化吗？”在医生进来之前，她通常就会告诉我没有变化，至少最近两次是这样，这让我大大松了一口气。所以我或许还能用自己原装的耳朵听到泰勒·斯威夫特的重录版专辑《举世盛名》（Reputation Taylor's Version）。但我学会了一种与人连接的新方式，并且我狠狠地支持了艺术事业。我懂得了代顿充满了这样伟大、勇敢的主角，而我们都还有时间成为其中的一员。
So thank you guys.
That was Lauren Karch.
Lauren is a writer and local government employee, and she says yes, it is just like Parks
and Rec, in the happiest place on earth, the greater Dayton area.
She tells stories in Dayton and encourages you to check out your local art scene.
Also, if you were wondering, the hot cello player.
who Lauren talked about in her story,
heard through the grapevine that he was mentioned on stage.
谢谢大家。刚才那是劳伦·卡奇。劳伦是一名作家和地方政府雇员，她说，是的，这感觉就像《公园与游憩》，就在地球上最快乐的地方——大代顿地区。她在代顿讲述故事，并鼓励大家去了解当地的艺术圈。另外，如果你想知道的话，劳伦在故事中提到那个性感的大提琴手，听说他自己也在舞台上被提及了。
We hope you're listening, Hot Chello Player.
The summer before my last semester of college,
I had an internship in New York City.
I knew it was going to feel very different
from my Kansas college town,
and I was scared.
Enter Sean.
A friend of a friend who had just graduated
希望你在听，性感大提琴手。大学最后一个学期的前一个夏天，我在纽约市实习。我知道那里的感觉会和我的堪萨斯大学小镇大不相同，我很害怕。西恩登场了。一个朋友的朋友，刚毕业
and was moving to NYC to start a new job.
We made plans for a polite, lonely desperation meetup,
which turned into us hitting it
off in a real way and spending almost every free minute together that summer. We got our bearings,
stayed out late bar hopping and eating cheap food, and screeched in panic as his toilet overflowed
and flooded his tiny studio while I shouted, how do you turn off water at my dad over the phone?
A real bonding kind of summer. Almost 15 years later, I am no better at troubleshooting plumbing issues,
and he is still one of my closest friends. Our next story is from Valerie Walker,
并搬到纽约开始新工作。我们计划了一次客气而又带着孤独绝望感的见面，结果却意外地合拍，那个夏天我们几乎把所有空闲时间都腻在一起。我们逐渐适应了环境，经常深夜泡酒吧、吃廉价快餐，当他的马桶溢水把小单身公寓给淹了的时候，我俩在一旁惊慌失措地尖叫，而我在电话里冲我爸大喊：“怎么把水关掉？”这是一段充满羁绊的夏天。将近15年后的今天，我在解决水管故障方面依然没有半点长进，而他依然是我最亲密的朋友之一。我们的下一个故事来自瓦莱里·沃克，
who told it at a story slam where the theme was chemistry.
Here's Valerie, live at the moth.
So on Sunday, I had a reunion with a woman that I went to college with.
I hadn't seen her for 34 years.
I know I look good.
And the thing, you're probably wondering after 34 years, like, what do you care?
I had actually been caring her in my heart for the intervening time.
And we were an odd pair, for sure.
她在一个以“化学反应”为主题的故事滑稽朗诵会上讲述了这个故事。有请瓦莱里，亲临“蛾子”故事会现场。事情是这样的，周日我和一个大学时期的女同学重聚了。我们有34年没见了。我知道我保养得很好。而且你可能会想，在34年之后，怎么还会把对方放在心上？其实在这些年里，我一直把她装在心里。我们俩绝对是一对奇怪的组合。
We met in college a very impressionable time.
She was from a small town in Arkansas.
I still had the grit from New York City in my pockets.
She was artful with her makeup and painted on a natural-looking face
and smelled like beautiful perfume.
And I smelled like a mix of soap and whatever moisturizer.
I was using.
And so looking at us, you would think, like, what do they have in common?
我们在大学相识，那是一个极易受外界影响的时期。她来自阿肯色州的一个小镇。而我的口袋里还揣着纽约市那种坚韧不拔的劲头。她对化妆很在行，画着一副看起来很自然的妆容，身上带着好闻的香水味。而我身上则混合着肥皂味和当时用的某种保湿乳液的味道。所以看着我们，你可能会想，这俩人有什么共同点呢？
And I wondered that myself, but there was such, she was so kind.
There was such a space that we created that was just joyful and very, very loving and super
duper fun.
And then I came out as a lesbian.
And one of the ways that I processed my internalized homophobia was that,
I was suddenly scared that my really rich friendships with women were going to be called into question,
that she would no longer be as affectionate or wonder what was my motive for being affectionate back.
And we had such a great relationship.
我也曾这么问过自己，但她是那么善良。我们之间创造的那种空间充满了快乐、非常非常的有爱，而且超级无敌好玩。然后我出柜了，表明了女同性恋身份。为了化解内心深处的恐同情绪，我采用的一种方式是：我突然开始害怕我和女性之间那些极其丰富深厚的友谊会受到质疑，害怕她会不再那么亲密，或者会怀疑我对她亲昵的动机是什么。而我们曾有过那么棒的关系。
Like, I don't know that song, I love you, a bushel on a peck, a bushel on the pack, I don't know all the words.
But one day, she wrote that entire lyric on my door, like as a note.
Yeah, it was just adorable and very...
very, very dope. And we had this ritual where, like, when we would go to dinner, I would go to her room.
She would change out of her fabulously stylish outfit, but she was shy. So she'd go into her walk-in closet,
and then we would continue to talk while she'd change. And when she was in the closet, her voice would be muffled like this.
And then when she came out, it would be really clear. And so one day I'm in her room and waiting for her to change,
And I am playing with the stuff on her dresser,
比如，我不知道那首歌怎么唱，“我爱你，一蒲式耳加一配克，一蒲式耳加一配克”，我记不全所有的歌词。但有一天，她把整段歌词写在了我的门上，就像一张便条。是的，这太可爱了，而且非常……非常非常地酷。我们之间还有一个习惯，就是当我们准备去吃晚饭时，我会去她的房间。她会换掉那身极其时髦的衣服，但她有点害羞。所以她会走进步入式衣帽间，然后我们边换衣服边聊天。当她在衣帽间里时，她的声音就会变得闷声闷气的，像这样。然后等她走出来，声音就变得非常清晰了。所以有一天我在她房间里等她换衣服，
so I'm not really paying attention.
Her voice went from muffle, muffle, muffle, back to clear.
And so I look up, except she had changed the routine
and had come out of the closet not completely dressed in her sweatshepants and bra.
And she was very easy on the eyes.
Okay.
So.
Now in that moment, I'm saying to myself, don't stare.
我当时在摆弄她梳妆台上的东西，所以没怎么注意。她的声音从闷声闷气变回了清晰。于是我抬起头，结果她改变了常规，从衣帽间里走出来时并没有完全穿好衣服，只穿着运动裤和胸罩。而且她非常养眼。好吧。所以。那一刻，我在心里对自己说：别盯着看。
You're staring.
Oh, my God, look at her eyes.
They're higher.
And so I'm, you know, having a little bit of gay freak out.
And so, but we regulated, went to dinner and everything got normal once everybody had their clothes back on.
So, you know, super cool.
And I, she was just really.
just a great person, our friendship was so enjoyable,
你在盯着看呢。天哪，看看她的眼睛。它们在上面。所以，你知道的，我内心有点小小的同性恋式的惊慌失措。然后呢，我们冷静下来，去了餐厅，等大家都重新穿好衣服后，一切就都恢复正常了。所以，你知道的，超级酷。而且我，她真的就是……一个很好的人，我们的友谊是那么令人愉快，
and yet that's the casualty of being a lesbian, right?
It's the chemistry.
Women are so cool and dope.
It's really easy to fall for you guys.
It's just the hard part is finding out
the appropriate person to fall in love with.
And I'm not going to lie,
I slept with a few varying genders in college,
然而，这就是身为女同性恋的代价，对吧？也就是那种化学反应。女孩子们真是又酷又棒。爱上你们实在是太容易了。难点在于找出那个适合去爱的人。我不会撒谎，我在大学里和几种不同性别的人睡过，
meaning straight women, but she was not one of them.
And then after college, we lost touch.
And recently, she started following me on Instagram,
and then more recently,
DM me that she was coming into New York
and wanted to meet up.
And I went to the place at the appointed time,
and I was super curious about how it would feel to see her again.
意思是直女，但她不是其中之一。大学毕业后，我们失去了联系。最近，她开始在Instagram上关注我，更近一点的时候，她给我发私信说她要来纽约，想见个面。我在约定的时间来到了那个地方，对于再次见到她会是什么感觉，我充满了好奇。
I knew that she meant so much to me,
but I also understand that what means something to you
doesn't mean the same to somebody else.
And then suddenly she was in front of me,
and then she was in my arms,
and I was in hers, and it was a great hug,
a long hug, a strong hug,
one of those hugs where you just rock side to side.
我知道她对意味着很多，但我也明白，对你意义重大的人，对别人来说可能并不意味着同样的事情。突然间，她就站在我面前了，然后她把手臂环绕了我，我也抱住了她，这是一个绝佳的拥抱，一个长久的、坚定的拥抱，就是那种会让你情不自禁地左右摇晃的拥抱。
And then we stopped, and we sat down, and we caught up,
and we cried, and we laughed,
and we held hands when shit was super,
hard to say. And it was really beautiful. I could recognize it for what it was, a blinding, furious,
and beautiful love that it was absolutely okay to have, and that was not in any way base.
And we're sitting there, and I'm telling her how much her friendship is meant to me, and then
she flipped it and told me how much my friendship had meant to her, and that she's not nostalgic,
and she doesn't even have any pictures from college, but she has two that she's printed out.
然后我们停下来，坐下，叙旧，哭泣，欢笑，当有些糟糕的事情实在难以说出口时，我们便紧紧握住彼此的手。那感觉真的很美妙。我能认清它的本质：那是一种耀眼、炽热而美丽的爱，去拥有这种爱是完全没问题的，而且它绝不低级。我们坐在那里，我告诉她她的友谊对我的意义有多重大，接着她把话头转了回去，告诉我我的友谊对她有多重要，她其实并不怀旧，甚至连一张大学时的照片都没有留下，但她打印了两张带在身上，
and one of them is of me.
Yeah, I know, right?
And so it was just so affirming in that moment
to know that she was mine and I was hers.
And if anyone ever asks me about the great loves of my life,
she will be one that I talk about.
Thank you.
That was Valerie Walker.
其中一张就是我的照片。没错，我知道，对吧？所以在那个时刻，这种确定感是如此强烈，让我知道她是我的，而我是她的。如果有人问起我一生中挚爱的人有哪些，她绝对会是我所提及的一个。谢谢大家。刚才那是瓦莱里·沃克。
She is an activist, artist, and storyteller
whose stories challenge perceptions and build community through shared feelings.
Survival as triumph and vulnerability as straits are key themes in her work.
Our final story is from Matthew Dix, who told this at one of our open micke story slams in Boston.
Here's Matthew, live at the moth.
I'm sitting in the break room of a McDonald's restaurant in Milford, Massachusetts.
I'm eating an egg macmuffin and I am not happy.
It is the spring of 1987.
她是一位活动家、艺术家和故事讲述者，她的故事通过共同的情感来挑战既定认知并构建社区。将生存视为胜利、将脆弱视为困境是她作品中的核心主题。我们的最后一个故事来自马修·迪克斯，这是他在我们在波士顿举办的开放麦故事滑稽朗诵会上讲述的。有请马修，亲临“蛾子”故事会现场。我正坐在马萨诸塞州米尔福德的一家麦当劳餐厅的员工休息室里。我正在吃一个蛋麦满分，而且我一点也不高兴。那是1987年的春天。
I'm 16 years old and it's not the egg macmuffin that's causing me to be unhappy
because an egg McMuffin is the most guaranteed source of joy in my entire day.
But not on this day.
I'm upset because I'm about to meet my mortal enemy for the first time,
and I know it's not going to go well.
I've been working at this restaurant for two months now.
I actually live three towns away in Blackstone, Massachusetts,
but I found out that this place pays $4.65 an hour,
我今年16岁，让我不开心的并不是那个蛋麦满分，因为蛋麦满分是我整天中最有保障的快乐源泉。但今天不是这样。我很心烦，因为我即将第一次见到我的死对头，而且我知道这不会有什么好结果。我在这家餐厅工作已经两个月了。我其实住在三个小镇之外的马萨诸塞州布莱克斯通，但我发现这家店时薪是4.65美元，
and that's 20 cents more than the White Hen pantry,
five minutes from my house.
And I figured, even though it's a 30-minute drive,
of the 20 cents will absolutely make up for the time and the gas, which it does not. But it changes
my life in a really significant way because when I arrive here, I discover the joy of a clean slate.
I'm growing up in a tiny town, 82 kids are in my class, so the same 82 kids I knew in kindergarten,
and they remember everything. And so when you want to be something different or you decide you
could be something better, no one lets you because they remember everything. They still talk
这比我家门外五分钟路程的怀特亨便利店（White Hen Pantry）高出20美分。我想象着，尽管开车要30分钟，但多出的20美分绝对能弥补时间和汽油的成本，然而事实并非如此。但它确实以一种非常显著的方式改变了我的生活，因为当我来到这里时，我发现了“重新开始”的快乐。我在一个小得可怜的小镇长大，我的班级里只有82个孩子，所以我认识的还是幼儿园里的那同82个孩子，他们记得所有的事情。所以当你想要变得与众不同，或者你决定自己可以变得更好时，没有人会允许你，因为他们什么都记得。他们到现在还在谈论
about the time in sixth grade when I exposed myself to class because my gym shorts were a little
too short and my underwear was a little too big and it was a little too much man spreading. They talk
about it to this day. And they remember the braces and the buck teeth and the bad haircuts and the
free and reduced lunches and all of that has prevented me from becoming something that I think I could be
and being trapped in what they think I should be. But I've arrived in this new town. Nobody knows me. And on the
first day of work, Aaron Duran comes and asks me if I have a girlfriend and the way she's hoping I say no.
And that's never happened to me before. So this is something. And it turns out that because they don't
know me, I can be the thing I think I can be. And suddenly I have more friends than I've ever had in my life.
六年级时我在全班面前春光外泄的那次经历，因为我的运动短裤有点太短了，内裤有点太大，而且腿分得有点太开了。他们直到今天还在谈论这件事。他们还记得我戴过的牙套、暴牙、糟糕的发型、免费和减价午餐，所有这一切都阻碍了我成为一个我自认为可以成为的人，让我被困在他们认为我应该成为的那个样子里。但我来到了这个新小镇。没有人认识我。上班的第一天，埃伦·杜兰（Aaron Duran）走过来问我有没有女朋友，从她问的方式来看，她希望我说没有。这在我身上从来没有发生过。所以这很不一般。事实证明，因为他们不了解我，我可以成为我心目中那个理想的自己。突然间，我拥有了比我一生中任何时候都要多的朋友。
And I'm good at my job, shockingly good. In 1980s, the job at the McDonald's that is the hardest is
running the bin. I have been a public school teacher for 24 years. And I can tell you that I have not had a day in my
classroom as taxing as a day running the bin at McDonald's during rush hour in 1987.
It is coordinating a kitchen full of 16-year-olds and 60-year-olds and convincing them all to do work
for you at the same time and watching a drive-through screen and listening to cash registers and
figuring out how much food needs to be here at any moment without causing waste and making sure
profit.
It's really hard.
而且我很擅长我的工作，可以说是惊人地擅长。在20世纪80年代，麦当劳最难的工作是负责备餐台（bin）。我当了24年的公立学校老师。我可以告诉你，我在教室里度过的那一天，其繁重程度都比不上1987年高峰期在麦当劳负责备餐台的一天。那需要协调一个满是16岁和60岁员工的厨房，说服他们所有人同时为你干活，还要盯着得来速（drive-through）屏幕，听着收银机响声，琢磨着任何时刻这里需要多少食物才不会造成浪费，同时还要确保利润。这真的很难。
And for some reason, I can hold all this information right here and I'm good at it and people
respect me for it. But as soon as I got good at it, all I heard was one word, Benji. You're great,
but Benji's better. Benji's the best bin person in this restaurant. Actually, he's the best person
in this restaurant. He is fantastic and everyone loves him and everyone respects him. And I hate Benji.
All they do is tell me how great he is and with every single word they say, I hate him more.
And then I discover they're telling him about me. And they're saying how this guy came in and he might be
better than you. They're spreading gossip about me to him. And so we have never met each other,
but we hate each other. And so this day, we're coming together for the first time. Our shifts
但不知为什么，我能把所有这些信息全装在脑子里，而且我干得很出色，大家都很尊重我。但就在我刚开始驾轻就熟的时候，我听到最多只有一个词：本吉（Benji）。你很棒，但本吉更好。本吉是这家餐厅最厉害的备餐台员工。事实上，他是这家餐厅最厉害的人。他棒极了，每个人都喜欢他，每个人都尊敬他。而我恨本吉。他们整天都在我耳边念叨他有多优秀，他们每说的一个字，我都更加恨他。然后我发现他们也在他面前谈论我。他们说有个家伙来了，可能比你还厉害。他们竟然在他面前散布关于我的八卦。所以我们虽然从未谋面，但我们已经恨上对方了。就在今天，我们要第一次碰面了。我们的班次
are crossing, and I'm going to meet him. And so I go out into the dining room at the end of my
break just to see him, because he's already working. And I see him, there's nothing to this guy.
Like, he's not that good looking. He's not an athlete. He's got the body of a bass player
and a failing high school rock band. He has nothing. But I watch in a couple minutes,
Later, I realize I'm wrong because he's funny, effortlessly funny.
And he's endearing to everyone.
He makes the older customers who are waiting for Big Macs actually happy to be waiting for
their Big Mac and the managers love him.
要交接了，我要去见他了。所以在休息结束时，我走到餐厅大堂只是为了看他一眼，因为他已经在工作了。我看到他了，这家伙也没什么特别的。比如，他长得并不是那么好看。也不是运动员。他有着一支在高中里混日子的摇滚乐队里贝斯手的身材。他一无所有。但几分钟的观察后，
And he's good at the bin.
Like he is really good at calling Bin.
I hate him so much.
And because he's doing my job, I have to run for drive-thru today, which is the second
hardest job in the restaurant.
80% of the orders go through the window.
so 80% of the food will pass through my hands,
but that means I need to work with the bin guy the whole time
我意识到自己错了，因为他很有趣，那种不费吹灰之力的有趣。而且他很讨人喜欢。他会让那些等待巨无霸的老年顾客们真的为等待巨无霸而感到高兴，经理们也很喜欢他。而且他很擅长管备餐台。比如他真的很擅长喊单。我太讨厌他了。而且因为他在做我的工作，我今天不得不去得来速窗口帮忙，这是餐厅里第二难的工作。80%的订单都是通过窗口完成的，
to coordinate and negotiate and make sure everything runs,
which means I have to work with Benji.
And so for the first hour, we don't talk to each other
unless it's about work.
And we clearly hate each other.
We're not hiding it in any way whatsoever,
but unless it has to do with work, I don't say a word.
And then after an hour, it gets, like, awkward,
所以80%的食物都要经我的手，但这意味着我必须全程与备餐台的人合作，去协调、协商并确保一切运转顺利，也就是说我必须和本吉合作。所以在第一个小时里，除了工作相关的事，我们一句话也不说。我们明显讨厌对方，根本没有丝毫掩饰，但只要跟工作无关，我连一个字都不会说。一个小时后，气氛变得有点尴尬了，
and I start to think maybe he thinks I'm afraid to say something to him.
So I'm like, no, I'm going to do something here.
And so I go up to him and I say, why are you coming in at 10.30 on a Saturday? What's 10.30? And he says, I watch Saturday morning cartoons. Which in 1986 is a thing. All the new cartoons, the Smurfs and the Snorks and Super Friends are all out in the morning. And we eat sugar disguised as cereal and we watch these things. And he says, the gummy bears start at 930 and they end at 10 and then I come to work. And he says it without irony or embarrassment. I can't believe it.
And so I walk over to the drive-thru, I drop a bag off, and when I come back to the bin, I say, listen to me.
Dashing and daring, courageous and caring, faithful and friendly with stories to share.
And I take some food, and I walk back to the drive-thru.
And as I come back over, he is singing before I get to the bin.
He says, all through the forest, they sing out in chorus, marching along as their songs fill the air.
我开始觉得也许他以为我不敢跟他说什么。所以我想，不，我得做点什么。于是我走到他面前说：“你为什么周六早上十点半才来？十点半有什么节目？”他说：“我看周六早上的动画片。”在1986年，这确实是一回事。所有的新动画片，比如《蓝精灵》、《海底小精灵》和《超级朋友》都在早上播出。我们吃着伪装成麦片的糖，然后看这些节目。他说：“《巴巴熊》（Gummy Bears）九点半开始，十点结束，然后我就来上班了。”他说这话时没有丝毫的讽刺或尴尬。我简直不敢相信。于是我走到得来速窗口，放下了一袋食物，当我回到备餐台时，我说：“听着：‘勇敢无畏，关爱体贴，忠诚友善，满载故事。’”我拿了一些食物，走回得来速。当我再次走回来时，在我还没走到备餐台前，他就已经唱了起来。他说：“‘穿过整片森林，他们齐声歌唱，一路行进，歌声响彻云霄。’”
and standing next to the bin with Benji, we sing together,
Gummy bears, bouncing here and there and everywhere.
High adventure that's beyond compare.
They are the gummy bears.
There's a second verse, a bridge, and another chorus.
I will not share them with you, but we sing them that day.
Because I watch the gummy bears too.
And to this day, I can sing that song.
接着，我站在本吉身旁的备餐台前，我们一起唱了起来：“‘巴巴熊，四处欢快蹦跳。无与伦比的奇妙冒险。他们就是巴巴熊。’”还有第二段歌词、桥段和另一个副歌。我不会唱给你们听的，但我们那天确实把它们唱了出来。因为我也看《巴巴熊》。直到今天，我还能唱出那首歌。
And that's it.
A single theme song to a cartoon melts all the ice between us.
And 37 years later, he is still my best friend.
It is the most significant relationship in my life, with the exception of my marriage.
When I get thrown out of my house when I'm 17, Benji takes me in and lets me live in his college apartment.
And when I'm 21 and I need a credit card and can't get one, he gives me his extra card and says,
just use it and pay me when you can.
He saves my life again and again and again.
就是这样。一首动画片的主题曲融化了我们之间的坚冰。37年后的今天，他依然是我最好的朋友。除了我的婚姻之外，这是我生命中最重大的关系。当我17岁被赶出家门时，本吉收留了我，让我住在他的大学公寓里。当我21岁需要一张信用卡却办不下来时，他把他的备用卡给了我，说：“随便用，等手头宽裕了再还我。”他一次又一次、一次又一次地拯救了我的生活。
And this day, we live in Connecticut,
two miles from each other.
And when I think back on that day that I stood at that bin
and sang a cartoon song to him,
I'm reminded how little it takes
to sort of reach out to someone
and just open the crack of a window.
And you just get the window open and then it becomes a door and it becomes a lifetime.
如今，我们住在康涅狄格州，相距只有两英里。每当我回想起当年我站在备餐台前为他唱起动画片歌曲的那一天，我都会想起，向某人伸出援手并打开一扇窗户的缝隙，其实是多么容易的一件事。只要你把窗户打开一条缝，它就会变成一扇门，进而变成一生的情谊。
Thank you.
That was Matthew Dix.
He's an elementary school teacher and novelist whose books include memoirs of an imaginary friend, something missing, and unexpectedly Milo.
He's the founder and creative director of Speak Up, a Hartford-based storytelling organization.
Matt loves ice cream cake, tickling his children, staring at his wife and not sleeping.
That brings us to the end of our episode.
Thank you to our storytellers for sharing with us and to you for listening.
We hope that this week and every week, your friends are there for you.
谢谢大家。刚才那是马修·迪克斯。他是一名小学老师和小说家，他的作品包括《虚构朋友的回忆》、《失踪的事物》和《出人意料的米洛》。他是哈特福德故事讲述组织“畅所欲言”（Speak Up）的创始人和创意总监。马修喜欢冰淇淋蛋糕、逗他的孩子们笑、凝视他的妻子以及不睡觉。这就到了我们本期节目的尾声。感谢我们的故事讲述者与我们分享，也感谢大家的聆听。我们希望本周以及每周，你们的朋友都会在你们身边。
Chloe Salmon is a director at the Moth.
Her favorite Moth moments come on show days when the cardio is done, the house lights go down, and the magic settles in.
Lauren Karch's story was directed by Sarah Austin Janice.
This episode of The Moth podcast was produced by Sarah Austin Janice, Sarah Jane, Sarah Jane,
and me, Mark Solinger.
The rest of the Maw's leadership team includes Gina Duncan, Christina Norman, Marina Clucay,
Jennifer Hickson, Jordan Cardonale, Caledonia Cairns, Kate Tellers, Suzanne Rust, and Patricia Orenia.
The Moth podcast is presented by Odyssey.
克洛伊·萨尔蒙（Chloe Salmon）是“蛾子”故事会的总监。她最喜欢的“蛾子”时刻是在演出日，当体能训练结束，剧场灯光暗下，魔法开始降临的时候。劳伦·卡奇的故事由莎拉·奥斯汀·詹尼斯（Sarah Austin Janice）执导。本期“蛾子”播客由莎拉·奥斯汀·詹尼斯、莎拉·简、莎拉·简和我——马克·索林格（Mark Solinger）共同制作。“蛾子”团队的其他领导成员包括吉娜·邓肯（Gina Duncan）、克里斯蒂娜·诺曼（Christina Norman）、玛丽娜·克卢凯（Marina Clucay）、詹妮弗·希克森（Jennifer Hickson）、乔丹·卡多纳莱（Jordan Cardonale）、卡利多尼亚·凯恩斯（Caledonia Cairns）、凯特·泰勒斯（Kate Tellers）、苏珊娜·拉斯特（Suzanne Rust）以及帕特里夏·奥雷尼亚（Patricia Orenia）。“蛾子”播客由奥德赛公司（Audyssey）呈现。
Special thanks to their executive producer, Leah Reese Dennis.
All Moth stories are true, as remembered by their storytellers.
For more about our podcast, information on pitching your own story, and everything else,
Go to our website, the moth.org.
I loved all the stories.
I know.
I thought they were also thought-provoking.
I mean, they're really great storytellers.
特别感谢他们的执行制片人莉娅·里斯·丹尼斯（Leah Reese Dennis）。所有的“蛾子”故事都是真实发生的，正如故事讲述者们的记忆所存。想要了解更多关于我们的播客、投稿你自己的故事的信息以及其他一切内容，请访问我们的网站the moth.org。我喜欢所有的故事。我知道。我觉得它们也都引人深思。我是说，他们真的是很棒的故事讲述者。
Yeah, I love, as you know, getting to know people.
And I felt like this podcast was just like a window into people's lives.
I absolutely love it.
Well, when I was listening to that first story about the young woman who's losing her hearing,
remember when I was talking about that book, The Correspondent?
Yeah.
In that book,
the main woman is slowly going blind.
对，正如你所知，我很喜欢去了解人们。我觉得这个播客就像一扇通往人们生活的窗户。我太喜欢了。说到这儿，当我听到第一个关于那个逐渐失去听力的年轻女性的故事时，还记得我之前跟你聊过的那本书《通信员》（The Correspondent）吗？记得。在那本书里，女主角正在慢慢失明。
Oh.
And she talks all about the things that she wants to see before she can't see anymore.
So it was really interesting to me to then hear this story about someone who wants to hear
all the things that you want to hear before you lose your hearing.
Anyway, it resonated with me because I think, and, you know, as we're getting older and after
all my health stuff in recent years, I'm very aware of the things that I want to do in my life.
and like that gal in the story,
I know, lady, you will be right by my side
哦。她讲述了所有她想在自己彻底看不见之前看到的那些东西。所以当我听到这个故事时，觉得非常有意思，讲的是一个人想要听遍在你失去听力之前所有你想听到的声音。总之，这引起了我的共鸣，因为我觉得，你知道的，随着我们年龄越来越大，经历了近几年所有的健康状况之后，我很清楚自己想在生活中做哪些事。就像故事里的那个姑娘一样，我知道的，夫人，你一定会陪在我身边，
making sure I check everything off my list.
I absolutely will.
I know it.
And I know there's going to be times
where there are things that you're going to want to do
that aren't with me
because that's the nature of life.
There's going to be some things on your list
确保我把清单上的每一项都打勾完成。我绝对会的。我知道的。而且我知道有时会有一些你想做的事情并不需要我同行，因为这就是生活本质。你的清单上会有一些事情
that are with Lee,
or with your kids,
or with your mom, your sister,
or your friends from home
or just a solo adventure, right?
But you will make sure I get all those things done.
sure it and then I want to hear all about it. I know. I want every detail. Well, I loved this episode
of The Moth. I loved the stories as well. But wow, Matthew and Benji really got me bonding over
是和莉一起做的，或者和你的孩子们、你的妈妈、你的姐姐、你的家乡朋友们一起，或者只是一次独自的冒险，对吧？但你会确保我把所有这些事情都完成。当然会的，然后我想听你讲讲所有的细节。我知道。我每一个细节都不想错过。好吧，我太喜欢这一期的《蛾子》了。我也很喜欢这些故事。但是天哪，马修和本吉真的让我感动到了，他们因为
that gummy bear theme song. Come on. And then there was something Matthew said that I just thought
was beautiful when he said he was reminded of how little it takes to reach out to someone.
That just really hit me because you never know where people are at in life. And those
small moments of kindness have a huge impact. And look, now Matthew and Benji have been friends for 37
years. Yeah. Lady, it made me think of that day you sneezed and I reached over with a box of
tissues at the inside of the office. I know. It's true. Your allergies plus my proximity to you
and to Kleenex. Here we are. Best friendship. Well, we hope that you enjoyed this episode
contribution from The Moth to access a whole bunch of episodes just like it, along with two
那首《巴巴熊》的主题曲而结下了深厚的羁绊。真的。然后马修说的一句话让我觉得太美妙了，他说他想起了向某人伸出援手是多么容易的一件事。这句话真的触动了我，因为你永远不知道人们在生活中处于什么状态。而那些小小的善举会产生巨大的影响。你看，现在马修和本吉已经做了37年的朋友了。对啊。夫人，这让我想起你打喷嚏的那天，我顺手在办公室里拿了一盒纸巾递给你的事。我知道。真的。你的过敏加上我离你和抽纸都很近。我们就这样成了最好的朋友。好吧，我们希望你们喜欢本期来自“蛾子”故事会的节目。想要收听大量类似这样的节目，以及每周两期的新节目，
new episodes a week, subscribe to the Moth wherever you get your podcasts.
We hope you have a great week.
And happy Best Friends Day.
That's right.
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies.
Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey.
Our senior producer is Matt Beagle and our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer.
Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis.
请在任何你获取播客的平台上订阅“蛾子”。我们祝你拥有美好的一周。祝最佳朋友日快乐。没错。感谢收听“办公室女士”。“办公室女士”是奥德赛公司（Audyssey）呈现的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔（Jenna Fisher）和安吉拉·金西（Angela Kinsey）制作。我们的资深制作人是马特·比格尔（Matt Beagle），音频工程师是萨姆·基弗（Sam Kiefer）。奥德赛公司的执行制片人是莉娅·里斯·丹尼斯（Leah Reese Dennis）。
Office Ladies was mixed in.
mastered by Bill Shultz.
Our theme song is Ruppertry by Creed Bratton.
Are you one of those media strategy people clicking through slides, scrolling spreadsheets?
Yes?
Good.
This is for you.
Because on Spotify, there's an audience that's different.
“办公室女士”由比尔·舒尔茨（Bill Shultz）进行混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里·布拉顿（Creed Bratton）的《Ruppertry》。你是那种在幻灯片和电子表格间点击滑动的媒介策略制定者吗？是的？很好。这段话就是为你准备的。因为在Spotify上，有着一群与众不同的受众。
Locked in.
Loyal, invested.
They're called fans.
Fans don't just listen to music.
They feel seen by it like it belongs to them.
So when your brand shows up on Spotify, that's who you're talking to.
And you're right next to artists like me, Lizzo.
So, are you ready to talk to fans?
全神贯注。忠诚，投入。他们被称为粉丝。粉丝不只是听音乐。他们从音乐中感受到被看见，仿佛音乐属于他们。所以，当你的品牌出现在Spotify上时，这就是你在对话的人。而且你就挨着像我这样的艺术家，比如莉佐（Lizzo）。那么，你准备好和粉丝对话了吗？
Spotify advertising.
You're among fans.
Hey, y'all, it's Kelly Clarkson with Wayfair.
Ever order furniture online and wonder, what if?
Like, what if it doesn't hold up?
That sofa was four days old.
You should have ordered from Wayfair.
With Wayfair, there's no what if.
Spotify广告。你在粉丝之中。嘿，大家好，我是凯莉·克拉克森（Kelly Clarkson），与Wayfair合作。你有没有在网上订购过家具，然后心里想：“万一……”比如，万一它不结实怎么办？那张沙发才用了四天。你当时就该在Wayfair订购。在Wayfair，没有“万一”，
Just style you love and quality you can trust.
Visit Wayfair.ca.
Wayfair, every style, every home.
只有你喜爱的风格和你可以信赖的品质。访问Wayfair.ca。Wayfair，演绎各种风格，装点温馨小家。